some people did ask me to introduce
myself
I am Jonathan trance and it's a very
special edition
obviously we're getting started a little
bit later a few technical difficulties
but on we go and I'm joined here by a
pristine member jaysin woolum who was
kind enough to sit down he's gonna show
us some of his games he's been a member
here since May he's been coming to the
club he's been getting private lessons
going to all the classes he he started
at about 300 and now his rating just
shot up to 500 and it seems like it's
just gonna keep going up cuz he's here
you laughing at his rating he's getting
better
um so yeah he gained like 200 points him
in his last tournament and it he's been
putting in a lot of work and practicing
hard so I think it's gonna continue to
improve for him thank you so I've not
seen these games it looks like you got
two of them here what uh what do you got
for us
anything you want we'll cover it a or B
which ones B I don't know ah oh well
okay you people are gonna like the the
opponent here and it says white is GM
Canwest that's no notation C this does
his quotes not mine
GM can't West versus Jason woolum so
this was the July nights round three so
it's a game seven D with the five-second
delay so you're black
good head and look at it so if you
weren't here you don't get to see the 15
minutes of trying to make chess space
work and the answer to the question what
program are you using is chess base it's
the most most asked question okay
d4 and i know ken west loves the collie
so okay very very normal response d5 so
okay you just i had to play you six very
very reasonable perhaps you're just
gonna continue with Knight f6 c 596
something normal like this
problem so I wish my come over here to
laugh at both the bishops but he's not
here so we won't mention that uh okay
you went here let's just get a few moves
on the board for time let's get to that
whenever it gets interesting okay you
went here yes so far this is just just
normal game very very Ken West like and
people castled okay so this is it
definitely how you know Ken West likes
to play it's a very sort of modest setup
for white but it can be quite dangerous
there's often lots of sacrifices and
then why can't actually get a big attack
in a lot of lines so you do have to be
careful let's go ahead let's let's see
what happened to you now you went here
which is interesting see which is
interesting so you do have to kind of
decide this black what your big setup is
gonna be here if you guys have any
questions at any point feel free to
laugh stop me and ask so I mean I guess
the way I've I've actually had this
position against Ken West and I did a
plan with this so I played c5 and Knight
to c6 because this is this is sort of
the main main main line but I've
realized if you're playing can West
here's the big trick just just do
anything unusual just like just move
this Bishop somewhere and you know
they'll just be confused it doesn't have
to be a good move but he's just gonna
play lots and lots of the mainline
theory and he keeps telling me everybody
just plays the main main main line so
that's all he knows but he knows it
pretty well just cuz that's all
everybody plays so just play something
unusual when you play ken west there's a
Ken West strategy just anything just
some random move and then play from
there because then you won't know what
he's doing you don't have to know what
you're doing either it's just what I do
see three perhaps he's gonna play E for
so yes you are playing without the moves
c5 why did you play the move rook to e8
are you thinking that you're gonna put
your Bishop back and play e5 or
something
I was either thinking that or move mine
to go night of 9f 896 okay so you have
these yeah can't West always place the
collie like no matter what as opposed to
the London yeah so he doesn't play the
London he plays the collie he's got lots
of books on him
so just deviate play something unusual
and then you know then you guys are just
both playing chess I mean it does seem a
little bit slow because he is playing B
4 and it looks like he just did it right
away boom okay so he's breaking in the
center and all right so you got to make
a big decision here you decided to play
them off C 5 C 5 movie and if you are
playing to move C 5 I mean I just would
rather have my knight on c6 than here
but I guess you are going here for
little defense yeah I mean well in
general the opening is gonna be slightly
worse for black that's what white is
just hoping for a very small advantage
and it is kind of annoying especially
for the higher rated player and you're
facing the Kali because it seems like
what black should do is just like
equalize and get some boring position
which you don't always want to do but
obviously you can do that and then just
play from there but uh that's why if
when I've played them since my first
encounter with him which was just he got
some equal position and it was just like
really boring and I had to really fight
to win that game which is you know now
what I expected because I've also played
blitz games with them that there were a
little bit quicker but then yes I've
learned you just do something unusual
just make them think and then he falls
apart faster that's good that's good you
ready I don't know yeah and then it
looks like you blender a piece that's
just the feeling I get you played here
he played there sorry and then you went
here which blunders a piece if I'm not
mistaken yes but he didn't take this so
I feel like he blundered that you
blundered a piece I think for better or
worse you need to move this Knight yeah
sometimes I mean I guess so you get two
choices sometimes you can go here which
is you know obviously feels a bit
precarious but you know sometimes you
don't lose your night sometimes you can
go in here too
you know sometimes you don't lose your
night yeah so it's probably better or
worse that's probably what you have to
do but I think you have to move this you
went here and he did not take this but
yeah now cuz now if you take this he
takes here and he's up a piece but I
didn't happen okay very interesting very
interesting
that's after c4 he just moved it so you
in here alright did you write down
winning pieces good yeah this is bad
yes okay yeah make sure you wanna make
that yeah all right so now you have to
move this night so again you have you
have sort of two choices and I probably
would have liked to have gone here
earlier when the bishop was on d3
because then if I play Knight f4 and one
go I'm at least gaining a tempo on the
bishop and I can always if I need to
come back to g6 you decided to go here
and you know if he kicks you around you
know maybe you're yeah yeah all right
that's what that's what he did it right
away yeah he's not wasting to him now
all right your gums he's gonna undermine
you all right do you have a question b3
and then yeah here this is probably a
positional decision that I won't have
made so you took here I think I probably
would have just gone ahead and played b5
mm-hmm I'm just supporting it I mean
black it's the one that's gonna be
trying to get some some play over here
in the Queen side white is going to try
in the future to get some stuff going on
the Kings side and yes you you took
again I probably would have protected 85
and here also was interesting if I were
him I probably would have taken with a
pawn there's so many ways to take yeah I
think I would have opened this up for my
rook get my pawns intact he went here I
assume just with similar intentions now
obviously he does have some weaknesses
you know maybe if we can eventually jump
a knight into here we'll be looking good
so maybe we can control surface squares
if there was a pawn here then obviously
c4 would be protected it's like okay so
here's the positional threat now she did
go here very good made a good move yes
okay again yeah so if g4 then Knight h4
I don't really know what his next move
is all about okay so he went here and I
think this too is sort of a case of I
don't know he's just like well that's
the next piece I need to develop so
let's just develop it but I don't really
see exactly what the bishops doing on
that four so I'm trying to think of a
more constructive move for him let's see
so what is yeah so you play Bishop f4
yeah and okay so interesting so you went
b6 so you you don't have the the same
idea that I had of trying to control c4
and I guess it was just by looking at
the pawn structure we can see a backward
pawn on the open file so that's sort of
where I would gravitate my pieces you
know you even have this guy coming into
the light squares sometimes so you can
get you can get a lot of legal I thought
well I know I've seen some of your games
I thought maybe take the King
thank you no I'm saying yeah you know
what I'm talking about you um so yeah
what do you find he planning on just
going here day six you're a sex or peace
out
this also is a is a decent like squared
strategy I wonder if you should you know
stop it some some way he could probably
prevent your idea at least for a little
bit but he went to D - okay you
protected this pawn and again I think
white is just sort of making like
routine moves not really thinking too
much about the position that is illegal
you know he's just getting his stuff out
yeah I don't see it yeah mm-hmm
ken west ranges between twelve and
thirteen hundred and we got a nail five
hundred player I'm about five hundred
yeah all your fine it's okay everyone
makes fun of it just going up it's gone
I think was still under the 25 yeah
we're still provisional I think we're
close to it we're close close to yeah
we're close to that official rate 26 so
here yeah I'm good also surprised never
understood why is 26 games that's a good
number that's why you need sure
okay excellent question yeah what are
the the ideas here so mmm-hmm yeah we
should do something on the kingside so
you'll notice it's got a lot of pieces
so if he's this is like sort of a long
way away from you know ever crashing
through and when you play this way
Macauley
when you watch a lot of games you'll
notice white is always playing for like
checkmating attacks it looks like white
is not doing that here me too and then
here you they should played here which
okay again this is a move I don't
necessarily agree with
I thought you'd prefer fuchsia Pisa I do
prefer Bishop a6 so not only am i
gaining a tempo on the rook I just feel
like this is the better diagonal for the
bishop because okay if white wants to
get rid of his weakness in the future he
might play a move like c4 sometimes
white can think about crushing me like
imagine my bishops not there you know c4
and if I take I can just push and I
crush you in the center these are the
sort of things I'm trying to avoid and I
mean this is a backwards pawn on an open
file a semi open file and okay I'm gonna
get my rook here I'm gonna start putting
a lot of pressure on that and so you at
least have something that you're working
with here as black okay but it's sorry
see you in here
you have to explain you have to explain
the next move to me you went here did
you know what did you know that's all
about night see warmer yeah what's that
all about
uh for him yeah um probably when he
played that did you like figure out what
he was attending man probably was either
trying to go to someone want to explain
that to me he's just gonna go defend
yeah he's gonna go passively defend this
just to double in the night mm-hmm
so yeah movies gonna take and then play
queen ha okay yeah even I could have
seen that I could have seen that or I
didn't so we'll see what happens with
that night see what happens can't wait
you don't like that's what the audience
wants to do alright is truthful yeah
waits a little better I think so too
probably like 0.7 let's get to the
bottom good I don't mind going back to
like here zero point zero zero this is
pretty 11 though but it depth 16 okay
what my place in the night place oh no
this yeah this was the July nights yeah
this was less this was last week right
fresh Spanish fact of the press
9f8 okay I think that's that's
reasonable bring it again yeah if you
ever take here I can take I can put a
knife here so that's that seems pretty
reasonable ninety-two all right so
Dennis LaRue knows exactly how can les
thinks very good very good
have you played in before yeah okay but
your intention wasn't to leave it here
you wanted to go get that Bishop he said
no you don't know why I don't know why I
would want to go get that dish I mean I
want to drive it away but I mean it's
yes I was gonna be on the night here on
that fate just for a little bit yeah
just to see you know I'm still wondering
if you're ever gonna end up taking this
and then I'll go to six and that's a a
five that was played oh yeah um what's
what's that all about
why don't I just want to understand
because I mean I'm I'm kind of worried
now cuz it's the same deal now yeah I
got a backup on myself yeah I'm just I'm
just wondering why you decided to play
that move I guess it's like did you just
have difficulty in this position coming
up with like a good concrete I think so
yeah cuz I mean probably I guess if I
were to do that I don't know why ace I
mean like I say six but and so if you
get this position you know a lot of
people I think this is like the number
one thing because I mean I've taught
hundreds of people the number one thing
that I think people really struggle with
is that you may get some nice position
like this you know okay it's computers
like 0.00 and they're like I don't know
what to do and when the center is closed
like this a lot of it is just looking at
the pawn structure because the pawn
structure is gonna tell you where you
want to put your pieces so so
immediately I noticed yeah I got all
these pawns here and they're not moving
anytime soon so I see this piece and I
think well he's not on a very good
square so the very basic thing you can
do a very basic strategy is improve
pieces that aren't good I also look and
so I noticed immediately okay there's
the potential to put
pressure on this file and that's just
how I come to the conclusion okay I
think you would be better on a wide-open
file
you know I want to also address this
pawn so that's just how these things can
kind of come into play it's just looking
at the pawn structure and using that to
decide where your pieces want to be so I
guess that's my big advice in this type
of position so what just happened
Bishop went age to a5 all right he wants
to trade the audience's question is what
is a the thought behind a 5 it was kind
of probably one of those that I was in
an even position and wasn't sure really
what to play yeah exactly that's why I'm
500 player right now right no I mean I
see this all the time it's people just
don't know what to do and then they do
something that when you're moving pawns
you know you are changing the nature of
the position because now your pieces
want to be in different places and so
that does change for white you know
you're giving him a target potentially
yeah yep the rep should go to see a
electron said mate to g3 so he is
threatening to win upon and you defend
it in an unusual manner did I yeah oh
good so I think I would you know take
this or move my knight or you know also
what's funny is now joke could be on him
you don't have that Bishop on that
diagonal anymore but I think I would
take this is kind of a problem because
he can at any moment
take this whenever he thinks that you'll
be able to exploit some weaknesses here
yeah but I you went here which I don't
know that that's a particularly good
square for the Queen um I don't really
know where you're you're playing on
going from there it does undefendable
pond and yeah that was that was my
panicking groups so I think both players
did that they just you know routinely
moved the queen of the way connected the
rooks
but you do want to kind of think
concretely about the position a little
bit more so now he takes which I think
is correct you take back and interesting
yep
does he have some crazy plan what could
this be all about just then you decide
to blockade with the Queen you probably
still you might still have time to go
back play g6 and drop the night in here
I don't know I mean at some point he's
gonna just win a free tempo here on this
pawn but I don't know so you decided to
use the Queen would you know sort of
known to not be the best black hater and
your Bishop is kind of stuck here
because you know okay this might even
happen yeah just to win the bishop so
that's the sort of thing is is in the
position oh you did it right away all
right he did it right away so yeah
basically you feel sort of compelled to
take because you don't really want to go
back cuz now I'm looking at e6 yeah they
took okay so wait is the bishop pair
flex pull it is sort of compromised here
okay and again night I didn't didn't see
this move coming well so you wanted to
defend your partner a step twice and you
decided to do it with the bishop I
suppose I probably would have gone with
this only because I'm thinking of the
future of this this piece yeah so I want
to get one of my rooks over to c8 now I
want to get my bishop on this diagonal
now now I'm not putting a rook on the C
file yeah and okay okay it finally to be
honest I don't think I did not see I did
not see no I did not see 97 um I'll be
dolls you just didn't see that you could
no I didn't see 97 yeah exactly
f4 to make this guy sillier you know
it's the move we wanted to play earlier
now it I don't do any selling much sense
so the bishop really doesn't belong over
here and so again I think it's sort of
when you're thinking of your your pieces
you want to try to find better squares
for your pieces so
I don't know maybe I would I'm thinking
h4 h5 or something I don't know what I
would do here let's see
Bishop c8 f4 and you know you had enough
of this Queen so I don't know if the
queen is actually well placed on g5 you
could probably ignore that I mean I
can't I can maybe I want to go here want
to fix
I want to fix all the problems let's
let's see what you did okay you keep the
Queen away she won't wait and okay so
again it's a decision with your bishop
so we're not gonna just keep saying this
every single move we've said it at the
point we decided to go here okay I guess
he does prevent you from going to
certain squares just let you go here was
the bishop on a4 where they do yeah it
was after after this nothing right now
but it's just a square that I have if I
if I need it just trying to see what's
different just weakness in the last move
so I'm just thinking about I'm not gonna
play ahead I'm gonna bring my roots to
the C file or something but it's just
something I want to pay attention to you
do have access to this in some lines
that might be useful
yeah I'm not thinking about doing it
right away b5 so is this yes this beep
on is it strong or weak what are you
thinking of going here yes okay cuz this
yeah this is a big positional mistake so
you'd be trading off his weakness to
create it your own weakness from before
so and that's why we learn to see one
protected name okay take the pawn yeah I
mean yeah
mm-hmm yeah I like attacking things that
are that are weak you work here now he
goes here all right fantastic no points
for my next move here yeah okay so is he
thinking g4j for open it up is he got
some some cruel intentions here and okay
so you did end up doing this which is
yeah a mistake so again right this is
the weakness so you want to be focused
on on getting his you don't want to get
rid of your opponent's weaknesses and
also you know you're creating your own
weakness by by doing that so here it
took check you check the great Ken West
that's excellent excellent Wow that's
what you played yeah that's what I wrote
so yeah I guess okay as I said I don't
know why now I'm thinking back hey you
might as well take this with something
yeah take take me what the rook might
also be okay cuz I I can go here and
here again I'm just looking at the stuff
that is potentially weak in the position
so this this was something that was
possible
you maybe take a look upon this I guess
I like taking with the rook and you know
I'm just trying to find things that are
potentially weak in a whites position
here you went here so you just I mean
you got to take the pawn back when they
take you
he went here please just he's like I'm a
solid pawn up I'm gonna go into the
endgame and everything's gonna be great
mmm protected pasture so it's just a
long-term advantage that he now has see
where are we alright welcome back
didn't get any better have you seen this
game already no hidden snow baby I
choose this one remember missing out
you're missing out the audience had some
things to say
okay you in here and I do like his move
I didn't I thought for sure he would
just trade cuz he's can't Weston you the
phone up but I don't know him as well as
Dennis does so I can't think like him if
I do like this move route to c5 you want
to trade with me you know I'll take back
and they'll ban off so many pastors okay
so you in here anyway we need to eat -
yeah I don't yeah I thought for sure
yeah and then you're gonna take that
pawn yeah thanks for reminding me about
that pawn
yeah cuz I don't want to made the move I
know I have to live my own mm-hmm yes
yeah
yeah if he ever gets to play B 5 then
the a pawn becomes a weakness and at
some point he's gonna try to do that
it's not one now it's in the works
you went to e2 just cuz just goes okay
so maybe he's just trying to trade he's
calculating you take me I take back and
then I take your a pawn it's good it's
good analysis I hope that's what he was
thinking
the world may never know alright solid
alright oh look at this improving his
worst place piece he's a genius he's
gonna go here before bishop somewhere
alright he's the best that's why you see
GM you you put those quotes now I know
that there must be a psyche it was him
that told me to hold you attacked a
weakness that's good so you attacked a
weakness and Korea one of my own you're
gonna like this next and now making that
oh oh it's Kent oh yeah that one you
guys didn't see that one coming yeah
thanks for him
also you didn't even see this move
coming either even more so even more so
you didn't see the squid comment mine
yeah sure so you want to put something
here you go here you're on this thing
and then when I protect it you're gonna
like okay well you can take new trade
Queens and Bishop e5 well then you're on
this so I just go here
because I don't mind I don't mind you
trading with me cause I think I just go
here
I don't mind you trading with me and now
I am threatening to take this and play
Bishop e5
cuz even if your Knights here now my
fondest defendant is in f6 of freak on
and uh yeah let's get back to the game
nine days f6
river words stayed for two moves and um
but okay this is pretty good for him now
seven yeah so this dig kind of happened
and now he traded here okay okay you're
okay with it no he now gave it that and
but look at this he attacked a weakness
that's pretty good you know that's
that's the most you can hope for see
traded which kind of got to I guess he
took here okay this is getting you good
so give me I'm waiting to hear what
YouTube says yeah go get you good get
them good tell him what you really think
you know we're trying to help them
improve he's a big boy take it
so here Bishop f2 and I thought for sure
you're just gonna go here or something
move your king up do something no you
can't you can't play the move here that
he played you just can't do it you can't
which one yeah yes ten times you know
whoa whoa that would be really bad
come on even I wouldn't make that one
he's trying to blunder the Queen you can
never guess this no make too much sense
that makes sense a little bit all away
closer getting closer
keep ahead exactly you know so he didn't
take and then take care he would be
expecting that yes I assume I assume
yeah I assume that yeah that was why
would he assume that it's not what he
did though this move is also probably
yeah yeah sure he takes you take them
right here with check all right you
ready
brace brace yourself buckle in at home
you know you probably want to be
drinking water right now you know you
probably want to be be sitting down g4
attack this is another way to blender
what was the the time situation now he
was in time trouble I wasn't so moving
on yeah
attack the Queen yeah does the thought
process yeah I mean I guess what were
you think I mean cuz obviously you're
everything is something go back again
and you're like go back well double so
many doubled pawns go back for a second
go back yeah take care oh yeah here you
play g4 which gives stuff away
yeah how losing is it though
oh let's see how long was five was at
all that's it he's only upper Brook man
mm-hmm
God wants to what it does after that now
I don't want to say it I either all
right take stakes yeah probably don't
even take back okay so we didn't even
take that but uh check you check the
great Jason woolum
the accomplishment and now I do what do
you where do you want to go audience
where do you want to go start crying
he ate that's what was play now what do
I played upon finish him off
checkmate Chuck may know that was not
play you know it's just as fast as the
checkmate one because he's resigned but
that'll have to do it we got Eric Hanson
here waiting to do his class so he's
coming right up if you'll stay with us
thank you Jason it was a very fun
entertaining so yeah thank you guys on
problem